only from the i-team new video and crime
scene photos in the murder case of
leslie palacio
eric grangelibara is charged with the
murder and right now
he remains on the loose his father jose
rankel is charged with helping his son
try to cover it up
evidence from that case shows how
prosecutors say it all happened
now we want to warn you some of the
footage is disturbing
the i-team's david charns has more
prosecutors say video from the morning
of august 29 shows 25-year-old eric
rangelabarra
helping 22 year old leslie palacio seen
here alive
get out of his truck and into the house
an hour later in video we blurred due to
its graphic nature
the same camera catches rangala and
another man who prosecutors believe is
his father
46 year old jose rangel dragging a
lifeless body from the home
and into that same truck minutes after
the truck drives off
leaving rangel hosing off the walkway
police say rengalabara killed palacio
and then left the country with his
father
these crime scene photos inside the home
showing a stripped bed
and blood spatter though investigators
say they have yet to determine whose
blood it is
investigators also taking photos of
gloves and cleaning supplies in the home
court documents showing rangel initially
told police that
eric told him palacio had died from an
overdose
he told police the first time he saw the
body was when eric dragged it down the
stairs of their home on a sheet
two weeks later palacio's body is found
off a road near the valley of fire
concealed behind the bush we need to
catch the main character
investigators arrested brandel near the
u.s mexico
border last month he told officers he
had driven to mexico with eric
and then they split up after that
palacio's family says
this is just the beginning we're not
going to stop until he's
eric is finally caught a grand jury
charged jose rangel with destroying
or concealing evidence and accessory to
commit murder
eric rangelabarra is charged with the
murder and destroying evidence
he remains on the run the coroner has
yet to release palacio's cause of death
i'm david charns 8 news now